Hallo, guten Abend. Mein Name ist Yücel. Ich bin hier den Staben der Arzt und für sich zuständig.
Ich würde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegespräch führen. Sind Sie einverstanden?
Ja, Hauptsache jemand hilft mir. Ich habe wirklich ziemlich heftige Bauchschmerzen.
Ich würde einige personische Fragen stellen. Wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Linus Müller.
Könnten Sie bitte Ihre Vorname und Nachname buchtebirn?
Ja, der Vorname ist Linus, L-I-N-U-S, ein männlicher Vorname.
Und Müller, M-U-Umlaut, doppel-L-E-R.
Okay, Herr Müller, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 27.
Und wann sind Sie genau geboren, Herr Müller?
27.04.1995.
Okay, wie groß sind Sie? Und wie viel wiegen Sie?
Ja, ich bin 1,78 kg und ich wiege 72 kg.
Okay, Herr Müller, was führt Sie zu uns? Welche Beschwerde haben Sie momentan?
Ja, ich habe solche heftigen Bauchschmerzen.
Und zwar, ich dachte irgendwie, das würde schon besser werden, aber dann hat das mit einmal heute Morgen ganz tüchtig wieder angefangen.
Also ich kann das wirklich schwer aushalten, es sind sehr, sehr heftige Schmerzen.
Und Sie sind so links im Bauch oben.
Okay, wann haben die Schmerzen angefangen?
Ja, dass die so schlimm waren jetzt, das war heute Morgen.
Und ja, angefangen hat das Ganze eigentlich damit, dass ich mit meinem Fahrrad gestürzt bin.
Ich bin also ziemlich zügig mit meinem Fahrrad gefahren und bin an so einer Bordsteinkante hängen geblieben.
Und bin also heftig auf die linke Seite gefallen.
Und dann hatte ich erst wirklich, also sehr starke Schmerzen auch im Bauch, auch so an der Seite überall.
Und aber nachher war das eigentlich besser mit dem Bauch.
Und mit einem Mal heute Morgen fing das an und war jetzt so schlimm, dass ich gedacht habe, ich muss sofort hier in die Klinik kommen.
Sie haben gut gemacht und wann sind Sie mit Fahrrad gefahren?
Das war gestern Abend, das war dann im Dunkeln, dass ich...
Sind Sie auf der linken Seite hingefallen?
Ja, und ich weiß nicht, ob da irgendwie... was war, ob da irgendwie so ein Mülleimer stand oder so.
Irgendwo muss ich gegen geknallt sein, das hat extrem weh getan.
Okay, hatten Sie gestern die Schmerzen?
Ja, ich hatte direkt nach dem Sturz tüchtige Schmerzen, aber dann sind die wieder weggegangen.
Und jetzt heute Morgen...
Also, nein, sie sind natürlich nicht ganz, aber sie sind halt besser geworden.
Ich habe gedacht, na ja, gut, hast du dich ein bisschen gestoßen?
Total weh, ja, selber schuld, wenn man hinfällt.
Aber jetzt ist es wirklich so heftig geworden, dass ich wirklich kaum das aushalten kann.
Okay, Herr Müller, wie ist das, wenn Sie die Schmerzen auf einer Schmerz sind,
wobei sie leichter sind, wenn sie die Schmerzen schmürzen?
Wie viele sind die?
Die sind bestimmt bei acht oder neun, also das sind sehr heftige Bauchschmerzen.
Okay.
Könnten Sie bitte dienst Sie, genau bei fünf Schmerzen, dass Sie sich drucken,
dass Sie sich drucken, dass Sie sich drucken?
Ja, drückend.
Drücken, ganz dumpfe Schmerzen sind das, ja.
Ja, drückend ist schon richtig dumpfer Druck, so würde ich sagen.
Okay.
Strahlung dienst Sie, in andere Körperregionen?
Ja, nee, das ist schon auf den Bauch da eigentlich beschränkt.
Meine Gonst tut mir glaube ich auch so ein bisschen, habe ich mich wohl auch gestoßen
und da habe ich natürlich ein paar blaue Flecken, das tut auch weh, aber das strahlt mich aus.
Sind die Schmerzen immer da oder treten die Schmerzen nur hin und wieder auf?
Nein, die sind wirklich, ja, so ein bisschen wählenartig,
aber eigentlich sind sie zurzeit ständig da.
Und also ich, jetzt langsam ist es auch so, dass ich, puh, dass ich ein bisschen so, so, so Angstzustände kriege,
so, dass ich wirklich ein bisschen Panik bekomme, weil die Schmerzen so heftig sind.
Ja, Sie haben recht, können Sie bis Ende des Geschenkbrech-Dischmerzen auftragen, aufhalten?
Aushalten, ich weiß nicht, müssen wir gucken. Also mir geht es echt schlecht.
Ja, und ich habe das Gefühl, mein Herz klopft also ganz tüchtig und es ist, also mir geht es nicht gut, das sage ich gleich.
Wenn wir schnell machen, dann könnte das klappen.
Ja, ich würde gerne schnell geben.
Und Sie haben noch Herzrasen, oder?
Ja, ich habe das Gefühl, dass mein Herz ganz heftig schlägt, ja.
Und haben Sie noch Herzstolpern?
Ja, weiß ich nicht, also bin ja kein Arzt, also ich habe das Gefühl, dass das Herz halt ganz schnell schlägt.
Siehen Sie eigentlich ein bisschen Bilett aus?
Ja, natürlich sehe ich Blass aus, ja klar.
Haben Sie auch Brustschmerzen oder Herzschmerzen außer Bauchschmerzen?
Nein, Schmerzen habe ich nicht, ich merke nur, dass das Herz sehr stark klopft.
Okay. Haben Sie außer Bauchschmerzen irgendein anderer Schmerzen?
Ja, das sage ich ja, ich bin ja hingefallen, da habe ich natürlich noch ein paar blaue Flecken an der Seite und an der Hüfte und an den Beinen.
Ich habe noch nicht so genau geguckt, wo es noch über Eier war, das tut mir natürlich alles weh nach dem Sturz.
Aber diese heftigen Schmerzen sind im Bauch.
Okay, können Sie Ihre alle Extremitäten anheben, bewegen?
Ja, das geht wohl, aber es tut weh ja.
Haben Sie eine Taupas gefehlt oder kribbeln?
Nee, das kribbelt nichts, nein.
Okay. Waren Sie vor dem Unfall oder nach dem Unfall bewusst sein verloren?
Hab ich das bewusst sein verloren? Nein, ich glaube nicht, ich war die ganze Zeit da.
Okay. Ist Ihnen Ubel oder Schwindelig?
Ja, jetzt im Augenblick ist mir natürlich schon schlecht, weil ich so irrsinnige Schmerzen habe.
Ich habe extreme Schmerzen, ja?
Okay. Okay, Entschuldigung. Haben Sie viel wahr?
Hab ich nicht gemessen, glaube ich aber nicht.
Haben Sie Stülfrost?
Nee, Stülfrost merke ich jetzt nicht, nein.
Okay. Haben Sie in nächster Zeit gewischt abgenommen oder zugenommen?
Nein, nein, nein, ich bin ganz gesund. Ich habe nur jetzt durch diesen Unfall, geht es mir schlecht.
Okay. Haben Sie eine Farbe-Ferenderung bemerkt?
Jetzt nach dem Unfall ist mir nicht aufgefallen, aber ich habe auch nicht so genau hingeguckt.
Und ich glaube Stülgang hatte ich noch gar nicht seit dem Unfall.
Okay.
Aber beim Urin war es mir nicht aufgefallen, aber ich habe auch nicht so genau geguckt.
Okay, haben Sie Erbrochen?
Erbrochen habe ich nicht, nein.
Erbrochen, ja.
Nee.
Okay. Okay.
Leiden Sie, Herr Müller, leiden Sie an chronische Erkrankungen, wie die Diabetes mellitus,
diese Tochter, oder anderen chronische Erkrankungen?
Ja, das habe ich schon seit Kinderzeit, das ist Neurodermitis.
Und seit zwei Jahren habe ich halt regelmäßig Migräneattacken, aber sonst so Krankheiten habe ich nicht.
Seit wann haben Sie Migräneattacken?
Also seit zwei Jahren.
Und seit Kindheit haben Sie auch Neurodermitis, oder?
Genau, ja.
Okay, haben Sie noch anderen Erkrankungen, oder leiden Sie an andere Krankheiten?
Nee.
Okay.
Ist Ihnen eine Allergie bekannt?
Ja, ich bin tatsächlich allergisch auf Amoxicillin.
Wie oisert sich die Allergie?
Ja, da kriege ich so rote Pünke, so Ausschlag.
Und haben Sie noch andere Unverträglichkeit gegen Lebensmittel?
Ja, also das scheint so, dass ich eine Laktose Unverträglichkeit habe.
Deswegen lebe ich jetzt eigentlich schon lange ohne Laktose.
Und da kriege ich halt Durchfall, aber wenn ich das weglasse, geht es mir gut.
Okay, Ihre Laktosintellerenz oisert sich mit Durchfall, oder?
Durchfall und Leihung, ja.
Deswegen lasse ich das jetzt weg.
Seitdem habe ich eigentlich keine Probleme.
Okay.
Herr Müller, nehmen Sie Rekell-Music-Medikamente ein?
Nee, ich nehme nur halt hin und wieder, wenn ich Migräneattacken habe,
dann in Schmerzmittel einnehme.
Welche Schmerz nehmen Sie?
Eigentlich nehme ich am liebsten Aspirin.
Aspirin.
Und sonst?
Ja, also für die Neurodermitis habe ich halt so eine Cortison-Creme,
wenn es ganz schlimm wird.
Wissen Sie, wie heißt das?
Nee, weiß ich nicht genau.
fällt mir jetzt nicht ein, nein.
Okay.
Sind Ihre Eltern an Leben?
Meine Eltern leben beide noch, ja.
Mein Vater hatte zwar vor zwei Jahren eine Krippeporation
und hatte eine Chemotherapie bekommen, der hatte Darmprobleme.
Aber da ist jetzt aus dem gröbsten raus und meine Mutter,
die ist so organisch eigentlich gesund,
die hat nur auf jeder Seite eine neue Hüfte bekommen.
Neue Hüfte bekommen.
Neue Hüfte lenken, ne?
Eine Endoprothese.
Ja.
Und seit wann hat Ihr Vater Krebs?
Ja, das ist so vor zweieinhalb Jahren hat man das festgestellt
und dann hatte er halt vor zwei Jahren die Chemotherapie.
Okay.
Und haben Sie geschwistert?
Ja, ich habe einen Zillingsbruder.
Ist er gesund?
Nein, er hat Asthma, aber sonst ist er gesund, ja.
Okay.
Okay, Herr Müller, ich würde gerne Ihre Gewohnheit wissen.
Was machen Sie beruflich, Herr Müller?
Ich arbeite bei der Deutschen Bahn als Kontrollieralschaffner.
Ich bin also sehr viel unterwegs.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich bin geschienen.
Wohne Sie allein?
Nein, ich wohne mit meiner neuen Partnerin.
Haben Sie Kinder, Herr Müller?
Ja, aus der Ehe habe ich eine Tochter.
Die lebt aber bei meiner Ex-Frauen.
Okay.
Haben Sie viel Stress oder Belastung in der Arbeit?
Ja, natürlich. Was meinen Sie, was bei uns los ist?
Es gibt keinen Personal.
Man muss immer wieder einspringen.
Und die Kunden sind auch unfreundlich.
Das ist schon ein echter Stressberuf, ja.
Sie haben sehr stressige Arbeit.
Und in Deutschland gibt es immer Personalmangelhaft.
Deswegen ist es normal.
Brauchen Sie, Herr Müller?
Ja, ich habe vor vier Jahren mit dem Rauchen aufgehört.
Ich habe nicht lange geraucht.
Aber vor 19 Jahren habe ich nie viel,
immer nur eine halbe Packung am Tag.
Also wirklich nie viel getroffen.
Okay.
Haben Sie vor vier Jahren Rauchen aufgehört?
Genau.
Vorher habe ich ab 19.11.
halbe Packung Segret geraucht.
Und trinken Sie Regalmusik und Alkohol?
Ja.
Ich trinke abends, wenn ich Feierabend habe.
Wenn ich gerade zu Hause bin, trinke ich gerne Glaswein.
Aber trinken Sie Regalmusik, jede Tag nicht Alkohol?
Fast, ja.
Nehmen Sie bitte nicht Person, nicht, das ist Routinefrage.
Haben Sie schon mal Kontakt mit Drogen?
Mit Drogen? Nein, also vielleicht mal mit Drogen abhängigen bei der Arbeit.
Aber mit Drogen selber, also ich habe das nie probiert.
Okay.
Und sonst schlafen Sie gut?
Oder haben Sie Probleme beim Schlafen, ein Schlafen oder durchschlafen?
Ja, ich habe natürlich deswegen Probleme, weil ich im Schichtdienst arbeite.
Und da kann man oft nachts nicht gut schlafen.
Oder wenn man dann endlich Feierabend hat, ist man so ein bisschen überdreht
und kann dann nicht einschlafen.
Und Sie haben keine Probleme,
surseit, beim Wasserlassen oder Stullgang?
Nein, ich habe nur dieses eine Problem, dass ich diese unglaublichen Bauchschmerzen habe
und dass mir wirklich es schlecht geht.
Okay. Und das ist letzte Frage, sind Sie vollständig geimpft?
Ja klar, gegen Corona bin ich geimpft, ja.
Gegen Tetanosis?
Gegen Tetanus weiß ich gar nicht so genau.
Da müsste ich mal bei meinem Hausarzt nachfragen.
Ich kann mit Ihrem Hausarzt sprechen.
Ja, ich bin mit meinen Fragen fertig.
Haben Sie noch Fragen oder wollen Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Ich möchte mich jetzt nur gerne irgendwo hinlegen, weil es mir so schlecht geht.
Ja, ich würde gerne Sie unsere Reaktion aufnehmen.
Und so erst würde ich Sie körperliche Untersuchung,
danach werde ich einige aparative Untersuchung durchführen.
Also ich finde, egal, was Sie machen, Hauptsache, ich kann mich jetzt irgendwo hinlegen.
Ja, ich würde erst auch ein IV Sie anlegen und mit IV einlegen.
Hast du es ein IV anlegen?
Ja, auch ein IV anlegen.
Können Sie das für mich als Nicht-Arzt mal erklären, was ist eine IV Anliegen?
Entschuldigung, das ist ein Zugang für eine Physikverabreichung.
Ein venöser Zugang?
Ja, ein venöser Zugang, ja, richtig.
Ich würde gerne Ihre EKG schreiben und Ihre Vitalparameter überprüfen.
Und danach einige aparative Untersuchungen, wie Ultraschall durchführen.
Dann werden wir eine Diagnose feststellen.
Sie können zur Sursight Immunzuräschitation bleiben.
Dann ist es eine Ausbildung.
Okay.
Okay, ist dann.
Haben Sie Veränderung auf der Haut, linken Oberbau?
Oh ja, ich habe Blausleck.
Wir müssen regelmäßig nachfragen.
Haben Sie bei einem Perkesson oder einem Kopfschuss getragen?
Ah, genau, ein Helm hat er getragen, ja, tatsächlich.
Er hat ein Helm getragen, ja.
Ich habe auch regelmäßig nachfragen,
aber ich habe nicht mit dem Schwindelik oder Schwarz vor den Augen getragen.
Haben Sie das beurteilt?
Ja.
Bei einem Umfall?
Das hat er gefragt.
Er hat gefragt, ob ich unwichtig war.
Und schwindelig hat er auch gefragt, schwarz vor Augen hat er nicht gefragt.
Aber grundsätzlich, das hat er schon abgefragt, ja, aber das habe ich verneilt.
Gestern, ich habe Nachts, schlafen Sie gut heute?
Nee.
Husten Sie oder atmen Sie nicht?
Husten?
Nee, das eigentlich nicht so sehr.
Ich glaube, Husten würde mir auch eher weh tun.
Deswegen vermeide ich das Husten.
Das passt.
Ja.
Noch andere Fragen?
Ich meine, es kam ja zu einem sehr, sehr frühen Zeitpunkt,
kam hier ein Hinweis eingeblendet, schriftlich,
Vitalparameter.
Ja.
Also, ganz sicher hätten Sie mit diesem Patienten,
nachdem Sie ihn ganz kurz gesprochen haben,
hätten Sie sofort ans Monitoring gehen müssen.
Ja.
Dieser Patient ist lebensbedrohlich krank.
Und ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob er tatsächlich ihre Befragung
überlebt hätte.
Ja.
Das, also da muss man ganz sicherlich unterbrechen.
Und muss sagen, wir machen jetzt paar Untersuchungen
und kontrollieren die Vitalparameter.
Und dann wäre der Patient eigentlich auch schon
auf der Intensivstation gelangelt.
Ja.
Das ist sicherlich absolut eine Indikation,
wo man das Gespräch, Gespräch sein lässt
und erst mal handelt.
Und dann kann man die anderen Sachen hinterherfragen.
Möglicherweise im Rahmen, was weiß ich,
wenn das EKG gelaufen ist oder so.
Aber ganz bestimmt wäre dieser Patient eigentlich nicht
in der Lage gewesen, zu sagen,
was seine Eltern für Krankheiten haben
und was er beruflich macht,
das wäre dem im Augenblick komplett egal.
Ja.
Und also das ist sicherlich so,
dass man da hätte unterbrechen lassen.
Oder meinen Sie anders?
Dr. Gündiz, was sagen Sie?
Nein.
Ich denke, diese Beurteilfolgende,
ich spreche, das ist wichtig oder nicht wichtig,
sagen Sie mir.
Ich würde gerne, ich möchte Ihre Vitalparameter überprüfen.
Vitalparameter, das heißt,
Ihre Blutdruckpulsatm,
Atm-Seichen und so weiter.
Und ich würde gerne einen Venetzugang legen
und einen Monitor anschließen
und sofort eine Ultrasynografie
und Röntgen-Traff
fernanlasst.
In der Zwischenzeit können wir
unsere Geschenke forcessen.
Ganz genau, ja.
Das ist genau der Punkt.
Also da muss man unterbrechen
und dann kann man ja jetzt in unserer Simulation immer sagen,
klammer auf, klammer zu, jetzt läuft also die Untersuchung
und jetzt kann ich weiterfragen.
Und dann liegt er da halt auf seiner Liege
und hängt am Monitor mit seinen Pieps, Pieps, Pieps
und was auch immer.
Und dann kann man natürlich auch fragen,
was, was ich, ob er Allergen hat oder so was.
Haben Sie alle irgendwie eine Medikamente Kontrast mit dem?
Ja, ja, das ist relativ vital,
damit er nicht irgendwas kriegt, was er genau jetzt,
was eine Situation noch verschlechtert.
Aber wie gesagt, die Frage nach Nikotin-Konsum
oder sowas, das ist dann im Augenblick wirklich mehr
als zu vernachlässigen.
Das kann man hinterher machen.
Aber natürlich muss man auch gravierende Vorerkrankungen
erfragen, ja.
Ob der schon irgendwie eine riesen Herzoperation
oder was hatte oder so, ne?
Dr. Ayri?
Können wir aus, ja?
Ja, ich bin auch bereit.
Sehr gut.
Hallo, guten Abend Frau Oberarstin.
Hallo, guten Abend.
Ich habe heute einen neuen Patienten aufgenommen.
Wenn Sie es halt haben, würde ich gerne den Fall Ihnen vorstellen.
Ja, bitte.
Der Patient heißt Hermula, ist 27 Jahre alt
und 1,78 m groß und 72 kg schwer.
Der Patient stellte sich bei uns wegen,
seit heute Morgen, plötzlich aufgetreten
er stärker Bauchschmerzen vor.
Er berichtete, dass gestern er mit einem
Fahrrad einen Unfall gehabt habe.
Nach dem Unfall hatte er kurz herzeit
linken Oberabbauchschmerzen,
aber danach seien die Schmerzen weggegangen.
Ganz weggegangen?
Ja, ganz weggegangen.
Heute Morgen, sein die Schmerzen wieder plötzlich aufgetreten.
Die Interstate der Schmerzen legen bei 8 bis 9
auf einer Schmerzkala.
Die Schmerzen sind auf der Schmerzkala.
Er hat die Schmerzen über die Schmerzen
und die Schmerzen.
Das haben Sie gesehen, dass er Blass war.
Das müssen Sie ja gesehen haben, der hat ihn ja gegenüber gesessen.
Ja, richtig.
Was haben Sie als Erstmaßnahmen gemacht?
Ich würde gerne eine Monitor anschließen.
Ja, haben Sie das schon gemacht?
Ja, ich habe das gemacht.
Dann würde ich direkt Blut abnehmen.
Und Zugang haben Sie auch schon gelegt?
Ja, ich habe das auch angelegt.
Und ich werde einige Flüssigkeit verabreicht.
Und kleine Blutbild- und Gerinnungsparameter
werden wir jetzt überlegen.
Ja, das ist die Schmerz.
Deswegen würde ich ein Ultraschall durchführen.
Was hat er denn noch weiter berichtet über seinen weiteren Verlauf?
Ja, ich habe das nicht mehr über den Patienten erzählt.
Was hat der Patient noch berichtet?
Sie haben den Patienten weiter befragt.
Ich bin noch gar nicht dabei, was Sie machen wollen.
Ich wollte nur wissen, was Sie als Erstmaßnahmen gemacht haben.
Als Notfallmaßnahmen.
Haben Sie mir noch nicht alles über den Patienten erzählt?
Jetzt müssen Sie erst mal Ihren Bericht fortsetzen.
Sie müssen doch erst mal erzählen, was Sie alles den Patienten gefragt haben
und was er Ihnen berichtet hat.
Vorerkrankungen, Medikamente, Lebensgewohnheiten, das alles.
Ja?
Ja, okay.
Die Patientin leidet an Neurodermatitis und Migraine.
Das ist eine sehr große Erleichterung.
Bei Ihnen ist eine Hüft-Tep weitseits eingesetzt worden.
Das ist kein Unfall, sondern eine geplante Operation.
Das ist eine sehr große Erleichterung.
Was machen Sie?
Was machen Sie als erstes?
Was Sie nicht richtig wiedergegeben haben,
direkt nach dem Unfall hat der Patient gesagt, da hat er sehr stark Schmerzen, die sind dann aber besser geworden.
Die sind nicht weg gewesen. Die waren nicht weg, sondern die haben sich nur verbessert.
Und dann hat er gedacht, dann wird es ja besser.
Dann kam aber der große Knall. Und mit einem ging die Schmerzen richtig tüchtig los.
Und das ist dann eben diese zweite Schritt.
Also ganz weg waren die Schmerzen nicht. Das wäre ja auch ein bisschen ungewöhnlich eigentlich, wenn der überhaupt keine Schmerzen hatte, da zwischendrin.
Aber gut, so weit, so gut.
Und jetzt machen wir mal, dass dieser Patient überlebt.